MANDY WHITE: Hi, I'm
Mandy White.
I'm a developer advocate working
on the AdWords API.
PAUL MATTHEWS: And I'm
Paul Matthews.
I'm a developer programs
engineer, also working on the
AdWords API.
MANDY WHITE: Today we're going
to talk to you about a feature
that was introduced into
the AdWords API
recently, called AWQL.
PAUL MATTHEWS: So
what is AWQL?
AWQL is an AdWords
query language.
It's a new feature introduced
in v 2012 06
of the AdWords API.
It's SQL-like syntax for
performing queries against the
AdWords API.
And it's an alternative to
using generic selectors.
It's available for selected
AdWords API services,
including Campaign
Service, Ad Group
Service, and a few others.
But most importantly, it's also
a [INAUDIBLE] querying
the AdHoc reports.
MANDY WHITE: So what is the
motivation for introducing
this new query language?
So the traditional methodology
used for querying, or making
queries against the AdWords
API, generic selectors--
can require quite a substantial
amount of code.
AWQL, as we will see
in future slides,
greatly simplifies that.
Also the AWQL syntax is
much more intuitive.
Any developers already familiar,
will code new SQL.
PAUL MATTHEWS: OK, so let's
start off with an example
service call.
In this instance we're going
to be calling the Campaign
Service, and we're going to
be trying to get hold of
Campaign's objects.
So we're going to give it the
criteria of CTR of greater 0
or 0.5 or so clickthrough
rate.
And we're going to be looking
for impressions over 100, and
during the month of
September 2012.
So that's the, sort
of, clause.
And then we're going to sort
the results by order of
impressions.
So this maybe code that
you are used to.
But they translate into whatever
language you're most
familiar in.
And basically this
is the Java API.
Java library for querying
the AdWords API.
So they are creating a
predicate, couple of
predicates, adding these two
selectors, and we're querying
the Campaign Service.
And getting back
a page object.
So that's the old code that
you're familiar with.
As you can see, it's quite
a lot of code to
query a simple request.
So this is the equivalent
using the AdWords AWQL.
You can see you're again
querying the Campaign Service,
but we're using the
query method.
We're passing in the
string, which is
similar to an SQL string.
But the main difference here is
that you don't have a From
clause, and you know it's more
tailored towards AdWords
specific stuff.
But as you'll see, you also
get a page object back.
So, the response is the same
as what you're used to in
previous requests.
And this is the alternative
using the Python library.
But it's a parameterized
string.
So this is probably more likely
what you'd be using to
query the service.
Again, returning the
page object.
So let's break that down.
To start off with, you're
supplying a Select, here you
pass in fields that you're
interested in.
You give it a Where clause,
and the criteria
that goes with that.
During, you're giving
it a time period.
And then you Order By, and
give it the order of the
results you want.
And finally , Limit.
In this example, we're
going to return
the first 50 results.
OK, so Paul's described to you
how we use AWQL against the
AdWords API services.
And I'm going to talk to you
about how we would use AWQL
against AdHoc reports.
AdHoc reports are very
simple to use.
You don't actually need to use
a client [INAUDIBLE] to make
queries against AdHoc reports.
Send a post request, HTTP
post request would do.
You'll supply some basic
HTTP headers.
For example, you provide
authorization, content type,
and customer id.
And in the body of the post
request, you will provide, for
the old way of doing it using
report definitions, you'll
provide an XML fragment.
The key value pair.
The key being underscore
underscore rdxml.
And the actual value being the
XML fragment, which is your
report definition.
Using AWQL is very similar.
You're parsing in the
same headers.
But we replaced the underscore
underscore rdxml, with
underscore underscore
rd query.
And this query again is a key
value pair, the value being
the query string.
Because we cannot actually
specify the query string, the
format, sorry, there are no
formats within the query
string, we have to specify
it separately.
So that's an additional
parameter we have to add to
the postBody.
In this case it's underscore
underscore fmt.
And the value for
that will be the
download format you require.
For example CSV or XML.
You don't have to
do it this way.
You can use the AdWords
API client libraries
to do this for you.
We have utility libraries
that will actually
write queries for you.
And here's some examples.
And now we're looking at a code
example of how you would
have done this with AdHoc
reports traditionally, with
generic selectors.
And again this is very similar
to the code that Paul showed
you for making queries against
AdWords API services.
In this case we create
a selector.
We specify the field
we require.
And then we assemble a report
definition object.
Report name, date range type.
What kind of report
we require.
And finally we set the
download format.
Then we use a utility library,
reportUtils, and again
this is Java code.
We have a download report method
on report utilities
library class.
And it'll be parsing an
authenticated API user.
A report definition object,
which [? we ?]
created earlier.
And an alpha string to where we
want to write a response.
How we would do that with AWQL,
it's a lot simpler.
Lot less code.
Obviously in this case, if you
look at it, this is a basic
java string.
It's not parametrized
in any way.
It's a select statement.
We specify the fields that
we are interested in.
In this case we have to specify
a From clause, and the
actual target table will be the
report we want to make the
query against.
In this case that's keyword
for [INAUDIBLE] report.
We also want to specify in this
particular example, we
want impressions
greater than 0.
So we don't want with rows
that are 0 impressions.
And we want it for yesterday.
We can parametrize
that string.
We can use string concatenation
in Java, or we
can use a string
builder object.
Or we can use a different
language and use the kind of
example that Paul showed
you earlier.
Then we can query, or make
a call against a report
utilities library, again.
This [INAUDIBLE]
download report.
We are parsing the authenticated
API user, this
time we're parsing
the query string.
And we also have to specify
the download format.
But this goes back to the
example we showed you in post
request, where we actually had
to specify which format we
required, because that could
not be included in query.
And the last parameter to the
call, is the alpha string
[INAUDIBLE]
write the results to.
So quickly breaking it down,
similar to how Paul broke down
the other example.
We have a Select statement.
And in this case we have a
mandatory From clause.
And we have a Where clause to
define exactly what parameters
we want to use to base
the query on.
And we always have to provide
a During clause which will
specify the date range for
which you want to pull
statistics from the report.
So let's summarize some of the
differences for AdHoc reports,
between AdHoc reports, and
making calls against the
AdWords API services.
As we've briefly shown, you have
to specify which report
you want to make the call
against, the query against.
And this will be specified in
the From clause of the query.
Also the During clause
is mandatory.
You have to specify a date range
for which you want to
make the query against.
Also because AdHoc reports
supports sorting and paging,
we have to provide an Order By,
and a limit, I'm sorry we
cannot provide an OrderBy
and Limit clause
for these query strings.
More details on the exact syntax
of these queries can be
found at AWQL documentation
at the following link.
Paul's now going to summarize
the differences between making
AWQL queries against AdWords
API services, and against
AdHoc reports.
PAUL MATTHEWS: OK, so firstly
the regular service calls.
So with the regular service
calls you do not
submit a From clause.
We mentioned it earlier. it is
the main difference between
AdHoc reports and service.
Additionally, the During clause,
the OrderBy, and the
Limit are all optional.
So you don't have to
specify those.
Moving on to AdHoc reports, the
During clause is mandatory.
The From clause is
also mandatory.
So you know, there's a lot more
that you have to submit
to an AdHoc report.
And the Order By and Limit, as
Mandy just mentioned, are
omitted because they cannot be
used with the AdHoc reports.
MANDY WHITE: OK, so we talked
about how we can use AWQL to
make queries against AdWords
API services and
against AdHoc reports.
There's a few tips we put
together about how we can make
the best use of AWQL.
One of the key messages we want
to pass on here, is that
if you decide to replace your
existing generic selector code
with AWQL code, you don't have
to actually change the way you
process results.
Provided the queries are
effectively the same, provide
the same kind of results, then
you can process them exactly
the same way.
So you can just plug-in your
AWQL code to replace the
generic selector code.
Also AWQL has a gigantically
small impact on report
generation performance.
And so basically you don't
really have to worry too much
about any performance decrease
when you are using AWQL.
And similarly there's no actual
difference in the cost
in terms of API units
between [INAUDIBLE]
or AWQL.
One thing we should mention
because of some of the quirks
of AWQL, there's a couple of
parameters that are not
supported in AWQL that you can
use with generic selectors.
Particularly for specifying
date ranges.
You can't specify All Time.
Not really quite sure
why that is.
And you can't specify
Custom Date.
Custom dates can be
provided though.
You just provide the
date ranges as two
separate time objects.
Date, time objects.
So that's not a problem.
You just can't specify the
clause, Custom Date.
So our call to action to you is
make sure that you use AWQL
the next time you define
a report query.
And so the next one we can show
is, how we can do useful
things with AWQL, like create a
command line interface tool
for querying report data.
PAUL MATTHEWS: OK, so we're
going to step into a quick CLI
sample app demo here.
To mean to show one way in which
you could use the AWQL
sort of feature.
So this application is
very, very small.
It really didn't take
a lot to write.
And I encourage you to do the
same if you're just curious
about sort of trying out AWQL
for the first time.
So all this does is it passes
the query off to the AWQL, to
the endpoints on the services.
And in this case we
are going to be
querying the AdHoc report.
So the first thing I do when I
get to this point is, I want
to sort of find the information
about the table
that I'm interested
in querying.
So for the argument's sake of
this query, I'm going to be
looking at querying the keywords
performance report.
So here on the reports
definition page we have a list
of all the fields that are
available to us, along with
some information--
some notes in the right hand
column, you know the behavior,
and a lot of good information
there for you.
So I'll start off by navigating
to this page and
then choosing the table
I'm interested in.
One good way to find this is, if
there's something you know
the name of, and you're trying
to find out how to get all the
information about it, is you
can just use your regular
built in Find field browser.
So we're going to be looking at
keywords performance report.
So then the next step would be
to go through, find all the
fields that you're interested
in and decide what your
criteria is for that
particular report.
I'm not going to go through and
select it all out now, as
it will take a bit too long.
But I have got one that
I've prepared earlier.
So again, using that command
line tool that I've prepared,
I'm going to be selecting the ad
groups, the keyword id, the
keyword text, the keyword
match type, impressions,
clicks, and costs from the
keyword performance report.
Next up, I want to specify my
criteria, which in this case
we're going to be using the
impressions greater than 0,
which is the same as saying
include 0 impressions False.
And then finally, we're going
to say the During, because
that is a mandatory field
for AdHoc reports.
So During last week.
And I query this report and
hopefully the result should be
displaced on the screen for
us in a csv format.
So what you can see here is
the response back saying
keyword performance report.
The date of the query.
The first line of the actual csv
is, as you'll see is sort
of the header columns.
So I have group id, keyword
ID, keyword match type,
impressions, clicks, cost, it's
all corresponding to the
criteria, to the Select clause
that I've fed into the query.
And then you've got
your results.
So they exist down to the
second to last line.
And finally on the last line you
have the totals, if you're
interested in that.
So here we've got a few
different keywords, things
being displayed.
And that concludes the
demo of the simple,
AdWords CLI query app.
We may have to go step
back into it.
OK.
MANDY WHITE: OK.
Thanks Paul, that's brilliant.
So just to quickly mention,
the reports, types,
documentation that Paul was
looking at then is available
in the AdWords API
documentation.
I'm sure you can easily find
it by looking that up.
So having looked at how we can
use AWQL against AdWords API
services, and also how we
can make use of AWQL
against AdHoc reports.
Looking at a particular example,
the command line
interfaces [INAUDIBLE]
AWQL.
Now we've pretty much finished
and wrapped up.
And we have the opportunity
to answer, that
you ask some questions.
You can answer the questions
for us if you want.
The more difficult.
PAUL MATTHEWS: [INAUDIBLE]
contributors can be involved
in that, I guess.
MANDY WHITE: Yeah.
So at the bottom there
we have a URL.
A very short link URL, which we
put in the first slide, but
we forgot to tell you about.
And you can use that slide, it's
the moderator page, to
enter questions.
I'm not sure we can do live
questions as well.
PAUL MATTHEWS: I don't think
we've got the Hangout set up
to ask live questions.
So this time it's just.
MANDY WHITE: Right, so we can't
do live questions, but
we can actually answer
your questions on
the moderator page.
Next time we do this, we'll
make sure we have
the Hangout set up.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Yup.
MANDY WHITE: So let's look
at the moderator page.
Paul, you want to go for it?
PAUL MATHEWS: Sure.
OK.
No questions as yet.
MANDY WHITE: OK.
So one of the questions I
actually entered myself was,
just to get things going, was
do we have to use a From
clause with queries against
API services, or not?
It seemed like there
was no need to.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Yeah.
So basically with the From
clause from the API services
you don't need to submit the,
sorry, for queries against the
API services you don't need to
submit the From clause because
that's implied by the
service in which you
are querying against.
So for instance, if you are
querying against the Campaign
Service, you're going to
be going querying from
that sort of data.
So you don't really need to
specify a From clause.
MANDY WHITE: Right, OK.
So those services, those, I
think, six services you
identified on the second
slide, they all have an
additional method on
them called Query.
So there's Get, Mutate,
and now there's
Query on those services.
And Query basically, if you're
using query on the Campaign
Service, then you don't need
to say from the Campaign
Service because that's
implicit.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Mm hmm.
MANDY WHITE: OK.
That's brilliant.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Let's try
refreshing the page, that
might bring back some
more results.
You can remain hopeful.
MANDY WHITE: Where are the
presenters is a popular
question [? as well. ?]
We are here.
PAUL MATTHEWS: We are here.
MANDY WHITE: Let us know if
you have any questions by
answering on the
moderator page.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Alternatively,
if there are many questions
left over after this studio,
then we will do our best to
turn them into forum requests,
and then respond to them.
MANDY WHITE: So basically,
on that subject,
we have an API forum.
We haven't linked to it here.
But you can easily find that
by searching on Google for
AdWords API forum.
That's fairly easy to find.
And we have [INAUDIBLE] by
both Googlers and talk
contributors.
So you'll get answers there.
You can also ask questions on
the YouTube page, and we can
try and do our best
to answer them.
I assume comments will
be open in there.
So yeah.
That's good.
So yes, I thank you guys.
Thanks for attending our Google
Developer live event
today on AWQL.
And we look forward to seeing
you again in the future.
PAUL MATTHEWS: And just
before we go.
MANDY WHITE: Just
Final slide.
There's some other [? events ?]
coming up.
If you do have any other
questions you want to ask,
specific questions about AWQL,
or about anything else in the
AdWords API, we have these
things called office hours.
Basically we have a bunch of
engineers, sitting on the end
of a Hangout for
an hour or so.
And you can ask questions
there.
These are the times
and the schedules.
PAUL MATTHEWS: And this
is a face to face.
So you know, you get answers
to your questions in real
time, which can be really
quite beneficial.
And also open a dialog
where you can ask
more than one question.
And also obviously we mentioned
sort of regions.
So for instance, in America,
New York, on
these office hours.
But that's not to say that you
can't join them from Europe to
the New York ones, you know.
They are open to everybody.
It's just that the time zones
suit the New York office
probably best.
MANDY WHITE: Yeah.
OK.
So thanks for doing
this today.
And we look forward to seeing
you again in the future.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Thank you.
MANDY WHITE: Bye bye.